Speaker 1: Nikki Haley crumbles like a pumice
stone. It's not a good analogy. I don't know
metaphor. She was asked three times by Fox News
propagandist Sean HANNITY. Can you tell me how
you differ with Donald Trump on policy? And she
was either unable to or unwilling to do that.
This is amazing to see. Let's get right into it.
I told you, based on her campaign launch video on
Tuesday, that Nikki Haley seems to be
making the argument. I'm like Trump,
but younger and a woman, which,
by the way, is identity politics,
which we'll talk about later. But it really seems
like she's unwilling or unable to draw any policy
distinctions. Let's take a look at this.
Speaker 2: If you had to delineate where,
say, you and President Trump differ
on issues, where would you start?
Speaker 3: Well, first, let's say
in reference to what the you know,
the thought of me getting into the race makes
the liberals heads explode. And so I welcome it
because it shows we're doing something right.
Speaker 1: Well, but you're not needing to
convince any liberals right now. You
actually need to convince Republican
voters because you're in a primary, Nikki.
Speaker 3: You know, when it comes to what
we're looking at now, listen to the first
20 minutes of your show. Look at everything
that's wrong in this country and tell me we
don't need new leadership. But the difference
is we need new generational leadership.
Speaker 1: Okay. So that's so far all we
have is we need a different generation
of people. Trump, 76. Nikki Haley is,
I don't know, at least 25 years younger
than that, I would guess. And so, so so far,
the argument is we just need someone younger.
Speaker 3: We have to lead the status quo. We
have to leave this chaos behind and we've
got to start talking about the future. You
need a Washington outsider that's
going to come in and say it's yes,
I understand that families are having
to pay more to make their grocery bill.
I understand that they are worried about their
children who may never get back from what they
lost during COVID. I understand the fact
that when someone's factory leaves town,
he's worried that his future went with it.
Speaker 1: So this is verbatim stuff, Trump
says. So far, not a single policy difference.
Speaker 3: Understand that you should not have
Americans looking up at the sky and seeing
a Chinese fire balloon looking back at them.
This is insanity and what we need.
Speaker 1: Remember, she's running
against Trump right now, not Joe Biden.
Speaker 3: Are a lot of changes. First of all,
we've got too many politicians in DC that
are past their prime. We have to have.
Speaker 1: So again, just there's
too many old people in Congress.
Speaker 3: We need to see competency tests
for any elected official over the age of 75.
Speaker 1: We'll get back to that,
by the way. That's interesting.
Speaker 3: We've got to stop the spending
addiction that is happening that is causing
inflation to go up. And we need to start realizing
that we don't need our politicians getting on TV
and talking. We need the people in D.C. doing
and we need to spark a fire up under them. And
that's what I'm willing to do. And if you
are tired of losing because we've lost the
last seven out of eight popular votes for
president, we're doing something wrong.
If you're tired of losing, then join me.
Speaker 1: I know you all noticed this,
but there is not a single policy
difference cited there with Donald Trump.
This continued. Sean HANNITY tried it again.
Speaker 2: Let me go back to my
original question, though, because, yeah.
Speaker 1: What you didn't answer, by the way.
Speaker 2: Anybody is looking or seeking
a nomination, is that you're going to be
comparing and contrasting your policy positions,
your views, what direction you want to take the
country with your competitors. Right now, there
is there's former President Trump is the only
other candidate for the nomination. We expect many
others, maybe even Mike Pompeo, who was on earlier
in the program today. Where do you see if you
see policy differences beyond what you mentioned,
which are generational differences? What
what specific policy areas would you would
you say part with Donald Trump now.
Speaker 1: By the way? Good job by
Sean HANNITY. Right. Well, good job because
HANNITY has already decided he supports Trump.
It's Trump's friend. So he's actually doing
like what we might call a real interview.
Speaker 3: What I am saying is I don't kick
sideways. I'm kicking for Joe Biden as the
president. He's the one I'm running against. Okay.
Speaker 1: That's code for I'm not going to
criticize Republicans. I'm going
to criticize Joe Biden. She's not
running against Joe Biden. In order to run
against Joe Biden, she has to defeat Trump.
Speaker 3: And what I'm saying is, you don't have
to be 80 years old to be president. We don't need
to have these same people going back again. We
need something new. We need a new generation
of fighters. We need people that understand
what the American, your average American,
is coming from. And we shouldn't be afraid to
fight for that. And that's what I'm willing
to do. I'm not going to kick sideways. I don't.
Speaker 1: Okay. I'm not going to kick sideways.
She's not going to criticize other people that she
is running against and who she has to argue she
is a better choice then. That's going to be very
tough to win then. Now, as interesting as this is,
their voters don't care about policy. So it
might not you know, they sort of are having
the last laugh in the sense that we look
at this and we go, she's not articulating a
single policy difference to Trump. I don't know
that she has to to win a Republican nomination.
That's the sort of sad thing. She may be
just does have to say the stuff that she's
saying. I don't know. HANNITY tried once.
Speaker 2: More to take the country with
your competitors. Right now, there
is there's former President Trump
is the only other candidate for the nomination.
We expect many others, maybe even Mike Pompeo.
Speaker 1: Okay. And so I'm realizing that that's
the clip we actually already looked at. Okay. So
multiple attempts there. And she doesn't draw any
policy distinctions. This was obvious from the
campaign launch video. The campaign launch video
contained no policy distinctions. And just her
saying it's time for a new generation. This is
apparently what she's going to run on. Plus,
identity politics, which we will talk about a
little bit later on. These clips, if you want to
check them out, are found on our YouTube channel,
YouTube.com slash The David Pakman
Show and also The David Pakman Show,
now in Spanish. You can find the Spanish YouTube
channel at David Pakman dot com slash Spanish.